you managed to find common ground with
george w bush that implies you'd find it
almost impossible to find it with what
everything he's saying look I didn't you
know the American elections up to the
American people but it's not clear to me
what these policies really are and and
if they are some of the things that have
been talked about obviously you couldn't
agree with them I mean an actual trade
war with China would be devastating for
both for both sides so I can't believe
that's what he will actually want to do
you know if you literally say that no
Muslims are going to come into America
that's not a policy we could go along
with okay now people often forget this
with someone like President Bush I mean
you know leave aside even foreign policy
he was someone who was in favor of free
trade he wasn't strongly in favor of the
transatlantic Alliance and of NATO he
was someone who worked with me on Africa
for example I mean President Bush had
the largest probably the largest
life-saving program that any development
and aid policy has ever had in Africa we
work together on debt relief poorest
African nations so there were lots of
things we could work on together and you
know I have no idea what a trump
presidency would look like